entrepreneur mark cuban never calls time
out i always look at business as a sport
and in football you play 60 minutes
basketball you play 48 minutes in
business it's 24 by 7 by 365 and the
whole world's trying to kick your ass i
will never forget talking to mark about
you know where are you going with this
broadcast thing he goes i'm going to the
bbc billionaire boys club
mark cuban parlayed his passion for
indiana basketball into a company worth
5.7 billion dollars the day that
broadcast.com was sold to yahoo i think
a lot of folks felt like we had hit the
lottery twice over the last 20 years
i've always been about what's new what's
next and how am i getting there first
the unorthodox entrepreneur has
disrupted every business he touched he
said we've got to blow this up this is
not what i want rip everything out and
start again he's been slammed
eliminated
and investigated mark cuban ordered to
appear before the sec but almost always
comes out on top he is smart being one
of the smartest people but he also you
could make the argument was one of the
luckiest people in the age of the
internet somebody has got to be the
luckiest person in the world somebody's
got to be right it's you and i'm just
glad to see you
[Music]
it appears that they are for sale on a
game by game basis but i can't figure
out how to buy them mark cuban got in at
the beginning of the internet boom and
it served him well
his gold mine was called broadcast.com
one of the first internet sites to
stream events live
everything from victoria's secret models
to countless sporting events
we were the first ones to scale internet
broadcasting you know to take
500 radio stations and broadcast them on
the internet 100 television stations
earnings calls product launches college
football games deals with the nhl major
league baseball i mean we had really
become a broadcast network on the
internet the fiercely independent
entrepreneur has blazed a trail into tv
movies nba ownership and he even stars
on a tv show though he declined to
participate in this one mark has been an
entrepreneur
from the moment the word was invented
before it meant drug dealer
[Music]
mark cuban was born in pittsburgh
pennsylvania and grew up in a suburb
called mount lebanon
from the get-go cuban was a money maker
selling trash bags newspapers and even
postage stamps
i started a stamp company i started with
a quarter and bought a stamp and left
with 50
thinking
hey if i could do this i could do
anything by the time he was 16 he had
already built a reputation
brian cuban is his younger brother i
remember mark being given five thousand
dollars by one of our neighbors to go
buy stamps in new york with my father
you know he was always the entrepreneur
at stamp shows but that just shows you
at that age what people thought of his
ability to make money
that skill only grew at indiana
university the tireless business major
taught disco started a chain letter and
decided to run a bar if he could come up
with fifteen thousand dollars
evan williams was an engineer at general
motors who played on the school rugby
club with mark cuban
he was at my house one day
he was calling banks to try to get a
loan so he could buy this bar so on my
way out said hey mark if you have any
problems getting that loan just give me
a call
two days later he goes hey ev
so i ended up late 1979 loaning mark 15
000 so he could buy a bar in bloomington
cuban awarded williams stock certificate
number one and within months opened his
bar motley's
wayne winston teaches graduate
statistics at indiana university in my
over 35 years of teaching
i've never had a student really start a
business while they were an undergrad or
an mba here on campus and he started
motley's which became by far i think the
best bar in town the business model he
used
in motley's is very close to the same
business models he used in his next two
or three businesses
he always would have 51
of it even though he didn't put up any
of his own money but no one really
complained because he was the one that
built up
the business
until it came crashing down after a wet
t-shirt contest it's pretty common
knowledge around town an underage girl
won a wet t-shirt contest
and so i think that hurt the future of
the bar let's put it that way
cuban graduated and soon landed in
dallas within a year the born
entrepreneur launched micro solutions
providing software hardware and training
to businesses at the dawn of the pc
revolution it was a family affair marcos
you come work for me so i said fine so
my first day at work and i'm big lawyer
i show up on my suit and tie
and he goes why are you wearing that
well you know coming to work for you a
micro solution no go home and change put
on your crappy clothes and your jeans
you're in the stock room
mark doesn't give you anything you have
to learn it and earn it
mark cuban learned the computer business
fast and in seven years sold his company
to compuserve for six million dollars
and i retired and you retired and what
did you do with that money your biggest
purchase my biggest purchase i bought a
lifetime pass on american airlines and i
had one mission in mind i've i wanted to
be able to go to as many countries
around the world as i could and get
drunk with as many people as i possibly
could and i was so good in 1995 mark
cuban came out of early retirement to
reinvent radio
according to cuban college friend todd
wagner brought him the concept
it's a story the hoosiers basketball fan
has told often as in this interview on
60 minutes
he sat me down he said look i've got
this idea where i think we can listen to
indiana basketball sporting events you
know anywhere in the world by using the
internet so mark and i just basically
said let's find out if this is a
business or not so we set up shop in his
upstairs bedroom of his house and you
know got us a computer got the software
and started playing with it and that is
the birth of audionet what eventually
became broadcast.com but another young
entrepreneur tells a different story
chris jabe says he was also a founder of
the company when i was pretty young i
was a minnesota twins fan i moved to
texas so as a displaced fan i was always
trying to figure out how to get access
to those games that i couldn't see on
regular tv when the internet came along
it's like it was a slam dunk because now
it was just a matter of acquiring
broadcast rights he took his plan to
investors one of them was cuban i
probably had this pitch that i'd given
to maybe 150 people over the previous
year and a half to two years and so i'm
getting into my pitch it's usually about
a 20 minute pitch and within three
minutes he goes i'm in i'll do it jabe
asked for a million dollars and said
that cuban wrote a check for ten
thousand and months later tried to cut
him out completely
mark said chris i really don't need you
you really don't have that much to add i
can pretty much do or get people to do
what you're doing
so i was a little bummed to say the
least and i really give todd a lot of
credit when he came to me and said you
know we can work a deal with you know
for 2 500 a month and 10 percent of the
company
in the way he described it in the way he
showed me the paperwork i knew it was
real and it really made me feel really
good actually even though
it was hard to take ten percent of a
company that i developed a hundred
percent from scratch cuban became the
driving force of audionet mark overall
really wanted to see it as his company
he had made it gone from really an idea
to reality he never really wanted to
acknowledge me as a founder but
co-founder todd wagner does acknowledge
jabe's participation he was there for a
very brief period of time and then he
went on to the next thing he owned a
slug of equity and did just fine
audionet did better than just fine
never before in the history of the world
could you come in and listen to almost
any team from anywhere in the world you
know a little pc and a connection to the
net and you might as well be sitting in
bloomington indiana
you'd go back in there and all they did
was have all these servers with all
these different sporting events going on
and people trying to keep the servers up
like what is going on in here they're
planning a nuclear strike
and you know but it was controlled chaos
in there keeping all those servers up
and all the the game streaming it was
pretty cool
cuban wagner changed the name from
audionet to broadcast.com in 1998 and
positioned the company to go public
the internet boom was in full swing and
on july 17th the stock hit the market
priced at 18 a share the first trade
pops up
and it was you know 63 dollars or
whatever it was i mean it was just
through the roof nada usina led the
sports properties and marketing
departments at the company i recall our
head of hr popping her head out of a
cube like a game of whack-a-mole and
saying
we opened at whatever the number was and
everyone looked up and we thought she
missed by a decimal she must be wrong
and we all started to look and you could
just see heads popping out and the
excitement in the room it was literally
like a parade went off the stock closed
at 62.75
at the time it set a record for the
highest percentage increase on an
opening day i'm the first to realize
that luck plays a huge part in it
i happened to have a company
broadcast.com
that went public at the right time when
the internet stock market was going nuts
cuban wanted to expand their content and
was looking for a breakout event
he found it in lingerie
there were a lot of pinnacle events for
broadcast.com and one of those was
certainly the victoria's secret webcast
wrapping high tech with high fashion the
webcast was a phenomenon millions of
people tuned in and it became the
largest viewed event ever on the web we
liked to position it as the first sold
out event on the internet it helped to
cement us as the go-to place if you
wanted to do something multimedia on the
internet jeff swaney is an entrepreneur
and friend of cubans from dallas i will
never forget talking to mark
about you know where are you going with
this broadcast thing he goes i'm going
to the bbc billionaire boys club you're
not going to make a billion dollars on
this thing i mean you're going to make
100 million dollars no no no dude no bbc
dude that's what i'm doing
in pursuit of that billion cuban and
wagner led the charge straight to the
executive offices of yahoo i remember
mark and i going into the conference
room and basically just saying look
we're where you guys need to be
so you're either going to have to
compete with us or you're going to have
to buy us because we are
big players in where we think the
internet's gonna go yahoo felt the
breadth of competition according to paul
saffo a leading technology forecaster
it's a moment where there's a sense of
the rise of the machines algorithms the
form of google are really taking over
the search space and it's beginning to
dawn on people that in fact there is
a lot of volatility and customer loyalty
around
places you visit on the web
i can remember going to yahoo
and you could just feel
the anxiety at the company of how do we
bulk up our technology side
looking for an answer in april 1999
yahoo grabbed broadcast.com for a
staggering sum
5.7 billion dollars in stock the deal
secured cuban's membership in that
billionaires club
i think a lot of folks felt like we had
hit the lottery twice you had this
tremendous ipo and to top it off
one of the the great companies in
silicon valley yahoo comes in and
acquires this little old company that
was set up in deep ellum dallas texas
it couldn't have been frankly scripted
any better
but not scripted all that well for yahoo
it is so easy to quarterback this thing
and as people say it's one of the
stupidest moves in the history of the
internet but
there was so much stupidity in that
period it was like a single note in a
vast symphony of stupidity yahoo
struggled with their new acquisition
it's pretty simple to to see what
happened if you're on the inside
you had a five billion dollar
acquisition handed to a number of nbas
who would never actually integrated
anything before yahoo really took a
pounding they took their eye off the
ball of search which opened the door for
google who smoked them within months of
the buyout cuban protected a stock by
buying puts and calls against his
interest and began to cash out buying a
24 000 square foot mansion and a 41
million dollar jet
but his next purchase would be the
billionaire's prize possession
in january 2000 sports fanatic mark
cuban bought majority ownership in the
dallas mavericks from ross perot jr it
was the crowning purchase for the
billionaire with the insatiable desire
to win
except that the franchise had one of the
worst win-loss records of any team in
the nba
you've got to start giving these guys
who have been in damaged programs let's
call them the thought process that they
can win but they are expected to win
cuban was going to change everything his
way
terdima ussary the buttoned-up ceo of
the dallas mavericks recalled his first
meeting i didn't eat the whole day
because we're having dinner's house that
night and i want to be a great guest and
i was in suit and tie and
you know trying my sunday best as my mom
called it
uh he opened the door open jeans and no
shoes and t-shirt and we sat on this
floor and watched basketball for four or
five hours and ate i think i think was
cocoa puffs and uh doritos is what we
had in bottled water so
so it was again it was just a new
reality that new reality took effect the
moment cuban saw the traditional
wood-paneled locker room in the
mavericks new arena he said you got to
blow this up this is not what i want i
want a loft i want open ceilings i want
the guys to feel like it's a clubhouse
the place they'd hang out in we got to
get a pool table in here and we got to
get the dvds rip everything out and
start again in the clubhouse
the radical new owner booked first class
hotels for road games and would buy a
team jet with leg room for seven footers
all that stuff was new none of that
stuff had been done in the league before
nor had an owner worn a mavs fan for
life t-shirt or put his email address on
the jumbotron or broken custom by
ditching the skybox for courtside seats
and yelling at the referees no
control of the timeout and we have
control of the timeout marcus had plenty
that's gotten him in trouble scott
sashnik reports on sports business for
bloomberg news my favorite one
is when he said that a referee wasn't
qualified to manage a dairy queen but
when he said that dairy queen got upset
uh they wanted mark to know that their
managers are highly trained highly
skilled folks and so uh the guy
challenged mark to come down and serve
ice cream and to see how difficult it
really was there were probably six
helicopters hovering above this poor
dairy queen there were probably three
thousand people outside and he was there
auditioning on ice cream
he's a very very smart marketing guy
and if he can turn a negative into a
positive he will but cuban's courtside
criticism was a negative for david stern
the longtime commissioner of the nba i
think mark was
very impatient when he first became an
owner because he strives
for perfection and
he expressed his views in that regard it
wasn't a constructive enterprise to
publicly criticize our officials and
it's prohibited by our rules those rules
resulted in cubans first fine of five
thousand dollars
followed by fines of fifteen thousand
twenty five thousand two hundred and
fifty thousand one hundred thousand ten
thousand and one hundred thousand again
all in his first full season as an owner
my job is to stand up for my my guys and
if i think something's wrong i'm gonna
do something about it reporter john
schwartz followed cuban's career for 13
years that connects with people you
don't see that among many millionaires
they think they have to act a certain
way i don't think he cares
i think he honestly just could give a
damn what anyone thinks about him
cuban's hands-on involvement brought
immediate success attendance shot up
more than 35 percent the estimated team
value left 50 million dollars and the
mavericks went to the playoffs in 2001
for the first time in over 10 years
before he owned the dallas mavericks
they were the laughing stock of the nba
they were winning 15 games a year once
he took over their winning percentage
has got to be one of the best it's got
to be in the top five
[Applause]
despite their surging success that year
the mavericks fell short of the
championship
and success for cuban in the film and tv
business was also proving elusive at the
dawn of hdtv in 2001 he launched the
first high definition television network
called hdnet as he explained to charlie
rose we're available on cable we're
available on satellite but viewers can
go knowing that not only they're going
to get great entertainment but they're
going to get great entertainment and the
best possible picture quality the
network sputtered barely reaching 350
000 homes in its first year
cuban hit pause long enough to marry
long-time girlfriend tiffany stewart
throwing a reception bash on his home
court the american airlines center
by 2003 he re-teamed with todd wagner
and plunged into the movie business we
bought landmark theaters which was a
national independent theater chain
we invested and then bought magnolia
pictures a theatrical distribution
company
we built on a home entertainment unit as
well to that and all of a sudden we had
built a vertically integrated media
company meaning with production
distribution and exhibition all under
one roof in a way that frankly we had
not seen done before it gave cuban the
pieces to shake up the movie business by
releasing a film in theaters on dvd and
tv
simultaneously andy fixmer is an
entertainment reporter for bloomberg
news
back then nobody was doing this nobody
even thought that you would dare put a
movie on television before it was
released in theaters it just wasn't done
cuban's movies met with mixed success
some films like good night and good luck
had found critical acclaim and a niche
audience while others struggled
and there was a disappointment again on
the basketball court star dirk nowitzki
led the team into the finals in 2006.
the mavs were up two games to none when
momentum suddenly shifted
and the team dropped three straight
cuban was livid
[Applause]
when he was pissed
he may as well have been satan the
players literally ran the other way in
the locker room the miami heat are
champions of the basketball world after
their collapse in the championship
novitskiy publicly called for cuban to
control his temper for the owner who
hated to lose the loss was pure
devastation i believe he didn't leave
the house for three weeks and he became
a shut-in so what did it cost him it
cost him his dream really his dream was
to turn the mavericks into champions
mark cuban the former disco teacher
returned to dancing in 2007 in front of
millions
[Music]
mark likes as much air time as he can
get as long as it's fun and it's
entertainment for him he's going to do
it he appeared on almost anything even
hosting his own reality show the
benefactor canceled after one season
viewers were also in short supply on his
own network with its strange blend of
bikini-themed programming mixed martial
arts
and dan rather dan rather and dan rather
reports on hdnet is kind of my own
personal
indulgence you know i'm i'm a news
junkie and always have been damn rather
was doing a show for them which was
actually very good but the rest of it
was
just like a sargasso sea of just
crap
cuban had more troubles looming the
securities and exchange commission filed
a suit against him we're going to turn
now to the crackdown on insider trading
and it has ensnared billionaire mark
cuban the sec alleged that cuban dumped
600 000 shares of mama.com
as an insider trade
the 2008 lawsuit from the sec says he
sold shares of the company ahead of the
company's own plans to sell more
discounted shares to investors and
avoided three quarters of a million
dollars worth of losses
on his blog cuban stated the claims were
false the suit was dismissed in district
court but the sec appealed and the case
was reinstated in 2010
while cuban battled in the courtroom he
also prepared for battle on the
basketball court
he dealt for key players hired a new
coach and in 2011 the mavericks fought
their way back to the finals
[Applause]
surprising everyone the loudmouth behind
the team bench went silent it was
different i mean still people went up
and talked to him but he said not today
not me
talk to the players
with mark in the background it was this
other guy dirk nowitzki and the team
that mark had assembled
that in the end was able to win what
he's always dreamed of
we've had the ceremony inside the
building and all of a sudden this chant
broke out thank you mark thank you mark
thank you mark how many
times have you heard of a building
channing
thank you to the owner
that's pretty unique
with a championship banner finally in
place cuban rebranded hdnet calling it
access tv
in addition to ryan seacrest cuban
partnered with two of the most powerful
names in music and entertainment
he lives in dallas with his wife and
three children on his personal blog he
sounds off on everything from executive
compensation to personal health
whether brilliant or just plain lucky
mark cuban will always be looking for
his next big move he's going to
challenge conventions he's going to
change how people think he's definitely
a guy to always keep your eye on he's
brash he's not afraid of controversy
but he's also one of the most brilliant
strategic thinkers i've ever met is the
glass of water half full or half empty
mark's going to be the guy asking who's
pouring it you can look at things and
say this is the way they've always been
done
i like to look at and say well if
everybody's doing this way that's not
where the future is you have to look
somewhere else and
you know if that pisses people off
that's their problem
[Music]
you